philippe you represent one of the
world's major fiber companies tell us
how fibre has developed around the world
in the last few years
yeah we say fiber is a
is a 40 to 50 years history
there are three technologies basically
that were developed to make fiber
one was developed in japan
the second one was developed in the
united states
and the last one is the european one
it happens that after
the consolidation
history of the industry in europe
prismian is the owner of that european
technology and prism is by the way
by far the main fiber maker in europe
yes you have you have a massive plant in
france i think and several others around
the world just moving on from that i
guess because of the way fiber is
developing r d must be more important
than ever before our india has always
been important first to develop the
basics and now we are permanently
working on
adapting
our products to the latest needs of ftth
but not only
all kinds of fiber rollouts in the world
deserve
always some improvement
rnd is about uh first you need to own
the technology like we do as i said
earlier we we have we are one of the
owners of the fiber technology in the
world one one of the few
and then
we leverage on this to permanently
develop new products
in the recent years we have invented
prism has invented the concept
of the bend insensitive fiber which is
absolutely fundamental now on the market
for ftth applications for instance
we invented this year we launched the a
new
version of multi-mode fiber which is
much more
powerful in terms of capabilities for
indoor and data center applications
we permanently improve also the cables
we made
we make bays on our fiber this is an
example you see
some time ago cables were very rigid
difficult to install you were wasting
time installing them
now
you can find this kind of cables on the
market that
that are exactly of the same
purpose as the previous ones but new
generation very flexible
here you have
more than 1700 fibers in one cable that
is very compact very flexible very easy
to install
so we indeed we are permanently working
on this and it will i guess this is not
going to stop soon absolutely and the
amount of traffic and data going through
those cables now i guess the quality of
the cable is also very very critical
this is absolutely a key point we
we with with the increasing need for
fast rollout
and and and volume of products there
there could be a temptation to go to the
easy way
and try and install everything you can
find on the market
i would recommend that
we keep attention to quality because we
there is there is a lot of debate about
how fast
do we have to roll out the networks
and
which technology
do we have to choose
but there is something missing here
the missing point is that we are about
to build we are building
networks that are supposed to last 20 30
years so first of all they have to be
future proof
to guarantee that the service that we
will need from them in 20 years will be
achievable
without changing everything again and
reinvesting in everything again so first
the choice of the technical product take
the technical choice of products is
important
i would say that
not taking the latest developments now
means by definition than it learning
that in 20 years from now
you hold the risk of having obsolete
products that you have to
replace so reinvestment
that's one
the choice of the product
but second the quality of what you buy
and install is very important
in particular in the the access network
because the access network is not the
backbone that we
install once and never touch again
access network is about going close to
the home
meaning
if i want my connection now
i need to be connected physically to the
network
in my flat in my house
but then maybe six months later my
neighbor
will want to have the same thing
another manipulation on the same part of
the network meaning if we do not
install
good enough quality of passive
components like cables and connectors
we hold the risk of after manipulations
manipulation manipulations to have a
breakdown
and our tolerance to disruptions
in the telecom world is getting
fewer all the time so i think
we have to
do it once and do it right
which means
to to make the right decisions about the
quality of components that we put into
it
in order to be future proof
and in order to avoid disruptions when
we speak about
adding permanently new services like
the download the uploads of course but
to have internet of things
i'm not sure a car can afford a
disruption in the network because of bad
quality
when we'll be driving it in an automatic
way from a computer you see what i mean
so the the the the
the reliability of what we do is
important and it starts with the
reliability of the products that we put
in the infrastructure
also for rural we want to develop rural
broadband which is absolutely fair as
as as an objective
but i guess given the the
long payback of these investments held
by public fundings and all these things
i guess that we don't want to to have to
do it twice
absolutely so let's do it once and write
with the right quality this is what i
think is absolutely important today to
highlight because we don't say it enough
in my opinion
thank you very much for talking to us
thank you brian
so from prismian there a message that
quality is key if europe is to keep on
developing its fiber networks